foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday October 24th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
the Wall Street journal's annual Tech
live conference kicks off today over the
next three days some top Tech Executives
entrepreneurs creators and more will be
sitting down with members of the journal
team to talk about everything happening
in the industry from regulatory
crackdowns to how VCS are
re-strategizing and the staying power of
the pandemics tech Darlings to give us a
bit of a preview on what's to come I'm
joined by wsj's live journalism news
editor Sarah Castellanos hi Sarah thank
you so much for being here thank you so
much for having me let's jump straight
into the big gets here who are some of
the big name speakers we'll be hearing
from at this year's event
yeah so I would like to caveat this by
saying that I'd actually consider all of
the speakers on this year's program to
be big guts we did put a lot of thought
into this year's lineup but yes there
are some that are particularly relevant
right now because of just the size and
significance of their companies for
example we have Intel CEO Pat gelsinger
joining us there's a lot going on in the
semiconductor industry right now not
least of which is a Slowdown in demand
Intel is the largest domestic chip maker
by revenue and Pat was a really vocal
supporter of the chips act that is uh
280 billion dollar measure recently
signed into law by President Biden and
that law aims to boost U.S chip
manufacturing Innovation and also
competitiveness with China so it'll be
really interesting to see his assessment
of where the chip industry stands now
and in the future and also to kind of
get a look inside Intel's plans for
Innovation we also have Disney CEO Bob
chapek joining us Disney of course is a
Giant entertainment company and a huge
player in the streaming business that
business is becoming increasingly
crowded and competitive we'll also have
Lyft co-founder John Zimmer being
interviewed we have reported that Lyft
has slowed hiring along with many many
other tech companies and Lyft has spent
very carefully on driver incentives in
the midst of a driver short Edge so John
will be talking about that as well as
live self-driving car strategy and also
some more Mobility initiatives like
bikes scooters and car rentals we also
have snap CEO Evan Spiegel who will be
talking about the company's augmented
reality focus and how he's been
navigating the turbulent economic
climate this is another company that has
had to lay off some employees recently
and just re-prioritize things their
Shares are down quite significantly now
and you know as you can see the economy
and how entrepreneurs are weathering the
storm is a really Common Thread at this
year's Tech live now our guests include
more than just company Executives who
else can we expect to hear from yeah
that's right and I'm actually really
excited about this for one digital
artist people is joining us on stage his
real name is Mike winkelmann he sold a
piece of digital artwork for 69.3
million dollars in a Christie's Auction
that was a record-breaking sale and he's
really just ushered in a new way of
thinking about the value of digital art
and nfts we also have Ben McKenzie
joining us he is an actor probably best
known for his leading role in the OC he
spent much of the pandemic learning
about cryptocurrencies and he's been an
incredibly outspoken crypto skeptic
which which is a little bit ironic
considering how many celebrities have
touted cryptocurrencies and nfts in
recent months we also have Hayley Bieber
joining us she is a model and
entrepreneur and Haley is an example of
somebody who's really just harnessing
the power of social media e-commerce and
streaming to create a brand the Creator
economy is of course booming so her
business strategies will be a really
interesting one to watch we will also
have Tariq Trotter on the lineup he is a
Grammy winner and perhaps most well
known as being the front man and
co-founder of the hip-hop band The Roots
he's now also a venture capitalist and
he plans to invest in underrepresented
entrepreneurs so you mentioned some of
the topics our guests are going to talk
about but what are some of the big
interesting themes that will be covered
in this year's event that jump out to
you yeah so the economy jobs and layoffs
that is going to be a major major thread
throughout the entire event crypto and
nfts that's also going to be a pretty
big Focus the metaverse everyone's
talking about it the journal has covered
it extensively in podcasts and Reporting
we are definitely going to be talking
about that and the potential for the
business use case for the metaverse but
also the critical aspect of it we also
can't forget that Tech live is happening
the same week of the Elon Musk Twitter
deal which is as of now at least
expected to close soon
you know one of the things that a lot of
people always talk about when it comes
to Big Tech and especially in recent
years is about regulation what can we
expect to hear on that front
yeah so lawmakers have been cracking
down on big Tech and they have been
scrutinizing many aspects of Technology
including cryptocurrencies for example
and also social media so there's going
to be quite a bit of talk about that Pat
gelsinger as I mentioned will be talking
about the chips act which is one of the
you know most significant pieces of
legislation that was passed recently in
the tech sector and you know U.S China
competition is going to be a pretty big
Focus as well there's been a lot of talk
about how the US can bolster Innovation
and compete against China so that will
be a pretty big Focus all right that was
wsj's live journalism news editor Sarah
Castellanos Sarah thank you again for
joining us today thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing Tech live begins today Monday
at 11 30 a.m Pacific we'll have live
coverage of the event on our website
wsj.com and if you're a Wall Street
Journal subscriber you can head to
wsj.com Tech live for a complimentary
online pass I'm Julie Chang for the Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]